voilà alors je vous engage évidemment et
téléspectateurs et téléspectatrices à
faire cette dictée en même temps que les
passagers de la gabarre gabart c'est le
nom du bateau mouche sur lequel nous
sommes
madame monsieur la laver seul peut
attendre quelques minutes ainsi que les
courses donc prenez votre stylo prenez
du papier et testez votre orthographe en
même temps que les 122 candidats
finalistes alors le texte de la dictée a
été c'est l'oeuvre de madame micheline
seulement linguiste qui avait fait
d'ailleurs tous les autres textes avant
et ce texte les la rédaction et les
diableries du texte ont été revus par un
collège de correcteurs professionnelle
alors le jeu rappelle bien entendu que
les fautes mais ça vous le savez défaut
de ponctuation les fautes de majuscules
ne compte pas et puis attention aux
accents un m'étais bien les accents ou
aiguë ou graves
choisissez votre parti où la gauche ou
la droite sinon ce sera autant de fautes
et puis la dictée joël d'abord la lire
en continu
puis ensuite la dictée proprement dite
et enfin la relecture et je commence
donc par le texte
on continue sa vie à tout le monde est
prêt téléspectateurs les candidats on y
est allons-y
monsieur le président du jury votre
missive me convoquant obligeamment pour
la finale mais parvenu avant-hier et je
ne vous ce sel raid pas que je n'ai
décacheté diligemment c'est à la mi mars
que par ouï dire je me suis laissé
subjuguer par votre concours et que je
me suis fait inscrire au diable les
pique-niques bucolique et les après-midi
de lèche vitrine enfermée à double tour
dans mater baïd combien d'heures est je
travaillais cloîtré disséquant
assidûment les dictionnaires convient de
porte plume se sont relayés sur mon
pupitre
combien de bloc-notes de pense bête et
je remplis puis le virus de
l'orthographe m'a rendu tout à la fois
irascible quasi insomniaque et
tremblotante la s'arrêtera la dictée des
juniors je continue pour les seigneurs
j'ai même frôlé le psittacisme
mais brisons là car me voici aujourd'hui
intra muros qu'on me croie ou non
débarquant à paris ce matin même je me
suis trouvée désorienté quelques
labyrinthique
que m'est paru les couloirs du métro je
suis parvenu à grand peine au lieu-dit
la jeu du chapitre ix deux concurrents
qui s'est envolé forte et weygand dans
des complexes gorge de pigeons rehaussé
de cravate bleue barbeau ce serait entre
déchirés voir entretuer pour des
graphismes ambiguë je vis même un
timonier atrabilaire risquer une
échauffourée avec des mariniers tatillon
pour un plus que parfait obsolète à le
subtil rolly des bateaux il y avait il
un pied-à-terre plus extravagants si ce
n'est un bathyscaphe quoi qu'il en soit
j'espère que vous ferez mouche sinon
bonjour les ex-aequo une épistolière
finalistes allons-y
facile non
[Musique]
monsieur le président du jury
monsieur le président du jury votre
missive
votre missive me convoquant obligeamment
pour la finale
me convoquant obligeamment pour la
finale mais parvenu avant-hier virgules
mais parvenu avant-hier virgules vous
serrez pas
et je l aurais pas que je lai décacheté
diligemment point à la ligne que je lai
décacheté diligemment pointera la ligne
c'est à la mi mars que virgules
c'est à la mi mars que virgule par
ouï-dire virgules parrot idir virgules
je me suis laissé subjuguer
je me suis laissé subjuguer par votre
concours
parent
votre
concours et que je me suis fait inscrire
points et que je me suis fait inscrire
points au diable les pique-niques
bucolique
au diable les pique-niques bucolique
et les après-midi de lèche vitrine point
d'exclamation et les après-midi de lèche
vitrine point d'exclamation enfermée à
double tour dans ma thébaïde virgule
enfermée à double tour dans ma thébaïde
virgule combien d'heures est j'travaille
et virgules
combien d'heures est je travaillais
virgule cloîtré virgule cloâtre et
virgule 10,50 assidûment les
dictionnaires point d'exclamation
disséquant assidûment les dictionnaires
point d'exclamation
combien de porte plume
combien de porte plume se sont relayés
sur mon pupitre point d'exclamation se
sont relayés sur mon pupitre point
d'exclamation
combien de bloc-notes virgule ont bien
deux blocs notes virgule de pense-bête
de pense bête mais je remplis point
d'exclamation et je remplis point
d'exclamation wii 2 point pi 2 points
le virus de l'orthographe
le virus de l'orthographe m'a rendu tout
à la fois irascible virgule m'a rendu
tout à la fois irascible virgule quasi
insomniaque et tremblotante points quasi
insomniaque et tremblotante point fini
pour les juniors c'est fini pour les
juniors je continue pour les seniors à
la ligne
j'ai même frôlé le psittacisme point
d'exclamation j'ai même frôlé le
psychiatre sma point d'exclamation
mais brison la virgule mai
brisons la virgule car me voici
aujourd'hui intra muros 3 point à la
ligne
car me voici aujourd'hui intra muros 3
point à la ligne
qu'on me croie ou non virgule qu'on me
croie ou non virgules
débarquant à paris virgule ce matin-même
virgule débarquant à paris virgule ce
matin-même virgules
je me suis trouvée désorienté points
quelques labyrinthique que m'est paru
les couloirs du métro virgules
je suis parvenu à grand peine je suis
parvenu à grand peine
au lieu-dit points au lieu de 10 points
la virgule la virgule
je du chapitre et deux concurrents qui
virgule jeu du chapitre et deux
concurrents qui virgules ces temps voulu
forte élégant c'est en volume fort
élégant
dans des complexes gorge de pigeon dans
des complexes gorge de pigeons
rehaussée de cravate bleue barbeau
virgule rehaussé de cravate bleue
barbeau virgules
ce serait entre déchirer les virgules ce
serait entre déchirés virgules
voir entretuer virgule voir entretuer
virgules
pour des graphies ambigu points pour des
graphies ambiguë
pour des graphies ambigu points
je vis même un timonier atrabilaire je
vis même un timonier ratera billère je
vis même un timonier atrabilaire
risquer une échauffourée risquer une
échauffourée avec des mariniers tatillon
avec des mariniers tatillon avec des
mariniers tatillon pour un plus que
parfait obsolète pour un plus que
parfait obsolète
point à la ligne
ah le subtil roulis des bateaux point
d'exclamation à le subtil rolly des
bateaux point d'exclamation
y avait-il un pied-à-terre plus
extravagants virgules il y avait il un
pied-à-terre plus extravagants virgules
si ce n'est un bathyscaphe point
d'interrogation
quoi qu'il en soit virgules quoi qu'il
en soit virgules j'espère que vous ferez
mouche point virgule
j'espère que vous ferez mouche point
virgule
sinon virgules bonjour les ex-aequo
trois points sinon en virgule bonjour
les ex-aequo 3 point à la ligne
une épistolière finalistes une
épistolière finalistes et je relis le
texte
ça y est on est prêt
monsieur le président du jury votre
missive me convoquant obligeamment pour
la finale mais parvenu avant-hier
virgules et je ne vous scellerait pas
que je lai décacheté diligemment point à
la ligne
c'est à la mi mars que virgule par
ouï-dire virgules je me suis laissé
subjuguer par votre concours et que je
me suis fait inscrire points
au diable les pique-niques bucolique et
les après-midi de lèche vitrine point
d'exclamation enfermée à double tour
dans ma thébaïde virgules
combien d'heures rêve travailler virgule
cloîtré virgule disséquant assidûment
les dictionnaires point d'exclamation
combien de porte plume se sont relayés
sur mon pupitre point d'exclamation
combien de bloc-notes virgule de pense
bête elle remplit point d'exclamation pi
2 points
le virus de l'orthographe m'a rendu tout
à la fois irascible quasi insomniaque et
tremblotante
point à la ligne j'ai même frôlé le
psittacisme point d'exclamation mais
brison la virgule car me voici
aujourd'hui intra muros 3 point à la
ligne
qu'on me croie ou non virgule débarquant
à paris virgule ce matin-même virgules
je me suis trouvée désorienté points
quelques labyrinthique que m'est paru
les couloirs du métro virgules je suis
parvenu à grand peine aux lieux dits
points
la virgule jeu du chapitre et deux
concurrents qui virgule s'est envolé
forte élégant dans des complexes gorge
de pigeons rehaussé de cravate bleue
barbeau virgules ce serait entre
déchirés virgules
le voir entre tuer virgule rites pour
des graphies ambigu points je vis même
un timonier atrabilaire risquer une
échauffourée avec des mariniers tatillon
pour un plus que parfait obsolète
point à la ligne a le subtil roulis des
bateaux point d'exclamation
y avait il un pied-à-terre plus
extravagants virgules si ce n'est un
bathyscaphe point d'interrogation
quoi qu'il en soit virgules j'espère que
vous ferez mouche point virgule sinon
virgules bonjour les ex-aequo 3 point à
la ligne
une épistolière finalistes avoue bernard
ap
oui vous êtes fiers de vous avec ça je
peux vous dire qu'on a un peu souffert
ici du côté des personnalités du côté
des dactylos aussi des secrétaires aussi
parce que vous et tout remettre au pot
pour maintenant si j'ai bien compris
vous recommencez commence à des
corrections apportées au crayon je
recommence pour avoir une copie
impeccable
alors c'est amusant parce que vous savez
que il ya vraiment deux types de javie
dire de candidats il ya ce qu'écrivit
depuis ce qui qui travaillent qui
corrige et qui surchargent alors bus par
exemple qui est en train de se rallier
auguste fait une copie impeccable pas de
vraies difficultés gus
oui enfin on verra ça selon ce que
diront nos juges un gros pâté quand même
que vous venez de faire l'instant
attention richard joseph vous êtes
retrouvé
oui bien que vitrines sont intervenus à
d'ailleurs on ne donne pas le détail des
choses parce que la lecture se fait que
les candidats donc pas de détails sur
les mots ni sur les phrases justes votre
votre sentiment
mon changement de literie donc voilà oui
ou je sais pas j'ai fait quelques
quelques heures ça vous a pas semblé
trop difficile non pas exclusivement
jacques ferran quels sentiments aussi a
priori ça ne paraît pas très difficile
mais peut être at on fait des fautes
qu'on ne soupçonne pas toujours pareil
surtout dans les traits d'union l'union
les accents et les d'hygiène diligemment
les obligea on n'aime pas le détail mais
effectivement c'est vrai que tout le
monde un peu souffert sur ces mois là
rosy varte a beaucoup ri pendant toute
la dictée je sais pas s'il a un peu ici
s'il a fait une copie véritable elle a
beaucoup ri elle a beaucoup copiée oui
j'ai vu tourner un couvert pierre mas
dell'acqua vers jean-marc thibault
je crois que j'ai j'ai écrit un texte
inédit moi j'ai même à dicter à moi il
ya des mots qui vous ont vraiment fait
éclater de rire il a vraiment choisi une
dictée très difficile quand il a dit que
c'était plus facile goudet l'année
dernière j'ai vu un moment d'espoir
c'était horrible
bernard pivot et très adaptée regarde
dehors pour pas vous entendre
s'il a alors il me semble nous a pas le
collège de correcteurs nous avons jugé
qu'elles étaient un peu plus facile mais
ça veut pas dire qu'elle est facile
désormais c'est une finale de
championnat de france
on est content que ce soit on va
couronner les meilleurs en orthographe
de notre pays et la belgique et de la
suisse
alors pas quand même donner une unité
avec avec avec un hommage des pompiers
conventionnement à la langue française
quand même à oui c'est vrai on est
voisins juste à côté de nous là à la
langue française comme dit jean marc
thibault
ben moi j'ai trouvé tout difficile parce
que c'est ce que ce que disait jean
cocteau il disait que le verbe aimer
était le plus difficile à conjuguer dans
la langue française parce que bon son
son passé n'est pas simple sont présents
n'est qu'indicatif et son futur est
toujours conditionnelle vous qui peut
préparer quand même j'ai l'impression
non oui un petit peu
ben je vais aller voir bertrand renard
comment s'est passé pour voilà c'est une
copie chargé vous dans votre cas en fait
en deux
non mais
non mais c'est toujours le problème on
se dit c'est simple et puis après ans au
lit et on se dit tiens est ce que c'est
vraiment est ce que c'est vraiment comme
ça qu'il fallait l'écrire alors on sera
jeu des fautes via la faim ont fait 35
foot alors qu'on pensait enfin 3 avec
une manière de faire particulier vous
vous souligner les mots qui vous posent
problème oui effectivement pour s'en
souvenir mais c'est pas pour ça que je
vais changer de la patelière ça vous a
semblé comment ma femme inquiète
beaucoup parce que je les trouvais pas
très difficile alors j'ai dû faire
beaucoup de faussetés combien pensez
vous avoir fait faute
l'a3 du fichier l'a déjà une idée 10 30
42 cents j'ai pas deux je ne fais pas de
paris bon ben c'est tout à l'heure c'est
bien un dernier mot peut-être quand même
avec françoise giroud savoir comment
elle a trouvé
je ne sais pas ce que c'est double
barbeau c'est la question posée à benoni
pourra le faire tout de suite quand des
copies ont été enlevés pour le bar dont
vous pensez avoir réussi les dictées
j'espère que j'ai passé plus de cinq
fautes je trouverais ça formidable serai
très fier de moi mais je suis pas sur
trois tout à l'heure pour en parler
merci françois girault voilà bernard
basset c'est fini pour cette première
partie enfin presque
ben oui ça y est maintenant voilà on va
ramasser les copies et je le dis pour
les téléspectateurs vont se retrouver
six ans il veut pas diriger tation à
19h10 on se retrouve à 19h10 alors vous
aurez droit
les textos landreau corrigé de la dictée
avec des statistiques sur les fautes
commises
et puis ensuite le palmarès bien entendu
les champions de france d'orthographe
vous seront présentés alors à bon me dit
on me disait tout le temps raconté simon
a pour 5 minutes tout va bien alors on
aime le rendez-vous comme ça sera fait
alors ce sera paie donc alors maintenant
je peux aller moins vite et bergen que
nous aurons d'ailleurs notre temps tout
à l'heure les téléspectateurs auront
d'abord le corrigé de la dictée alors ça
va être très très bien fait avec des
moyens tout à fait moderne et puis vous
aurez d'ailleurs pour chaque mot
difficile pour chaque point noir de la
dictée comme dit jean cazenave le
réalisateur vous aurez vous aurez des
statistiques sur les faux le nombre de
candidats finalistes qui auront commis
c'est cette même photo
autrement dit vous pourrez dire tiens
j'ai chuté avec tout le monde ou bien là
malheureusement j'ai fait une fois que
je n'aurais pas dû commettre
et puis après vous aurez les on va
couronner bien entendu les champions de
france dans les trois catégories juniors
seniors professionnels et seniors
amateurs
et puis bien entendu nous retrouverons
quelques unes des personnalités que vous
venez l'intérêt envers les personnalités
sont ces personnes est à 4 leurs
principes en fin quelques unes ont quand
même du travail sont peut-être vus
m'enfin la plupart sont là et évidemment
nous célébrerons les meilleures elles
seront récompensés aussi a vu milan
parce que là c'est pas c'est quand même
un certain temps du beurre et moi je dis
je voudrais remercier la toux de
françoise giroud au prix littéraire 2000
jamais claude durand va je veux pas tout
parce que c'est courageux de venir c'est
courageux de venir parce que quand même
dictée difficiles et sont des gens qu
une grande réputation et qui n'ont pas
en risque la réputation bien entendu là
risquent pas parce que ça n'est qu'un
jeu encore mais en tout cas qui qui ont
le courage de devenir affronter une
dictée difficile c'est très bien avec
des moments la maison je vois pierre
mertens par exemple que j'ai observé
pendant qu'ils étaient dictés il écrit
avec une autorité comment s'écrit
s'arrête jamais c'est
ah oui alors vous savez que pierre
mertens c'est un et c'est un leurre raya
c'est un écrivain belge de langue
française et les belles séries sont
toujours formidable on a pas mal
d'ailleurs alors il ya beaucoup de
belges mais il ya une des grande
surprise des demi-finales joue un signal
c'est que par équipe
les suisses n'ont emporté sur sur les
belges ce soir vous aurez une
statistique tout à fait intéressante
vous aurez un classement par équipes non
seulement vous aurez les les champions
par catégorie mais on va comptabiliser
le nombre de fautes commises par tous
les candidats d'une même ville on
divisera par le nombre de concurrents et
on aura donc un nombre de mois un nombre
moyen de fautes par ville et on aura
donc un classement par équipes alors je
sais pas si paris sera premier ou lyon
marseille quand j'en sais rien mais
enfin tout cas elle se rasseoir il
aurait donc tous les renseignements ce
soir à partir de 19 heures dix ans
passés puis dix minutes pour conclure il
reste deux minutes cette dictée vous
avez commencé par là faire plus
difficile vous l'avez à peu radouci non
savez ça se fait très difficilement
mishin seulement nous propose un texte
puis après on intervient là on dit ça va
pas ça c'est trop compliqué ça il faut
la rendre plus amusante là il faut là
là le mot il faut que le mot soit
compréhensible il faut qu'il y ait la
même graphie dans les deux dans les deux
dictionnaires larousse et le robert et
c'est donc ça se fait petit à petit et
puis elle et fignolé voilà et puis à la
fin voilà ça donne ce texte là mais il
ya eu un mois de travail sur son texte
mais voilà on va ramasser les copies
comme andy résultats donc et
couronnement définitif à 19h10 c'était
la finale donc on sera vraiment qu'ils
sont les meilleurs
merci à tout à l'heure